[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente yo soy bar
ya que era calle una de cada diez
personas padeció hambre en todo el mundo
en 2021 así lo revela el más reciente
informe sobre seguridad alimentaria de
la organización de la onu para
alimentación y agricultura o la fao por
sus siglas en inglés su cálculo es que
828 millones de personas enfrentaron
hambre y ese número aumentó durante la
pandemia pues es 150 millones de
personas más que las que se reportaron
en 2019 y 46 millones más que las de
2020 primero una aclaración cuando la
fao habla de seguridad alimentaria no
sólo se trata de que las personas tengan
comida sino que estos alimentos sean
nutritivos y que se puedan conseguir de
manera constante pero esto es cada vez
más difícil de lograr la fao se lo
atribuye a la combinación de la crisis
climática conflictos como la guerra en
ucrania y contracciones económicas que
empeoraron luego de la pandemia de kobe
19 el resultado es que una tercera parte
de la población mundial enfrenta una
inseguridad alimentaria moderada es
decir que sus alimentos no son los
adecuados para una buena nutrición o se
saltan algunas comidas mientras que esa
inseguridad es grave para 923 millones
de personas lo que implica que pasan un
día entero o más sin comer durante la
pandemia la inseguridad alimentaria
aumento en todas las regiones menos en
asia mientras que en áfrica y en américa
latina y el caribe alcanzó porcentajes
que no se veían desde 2014 cuando la fao
comenzó a hacer la escala y es que el
57,9 por ciento de quienes viven en
áfrica está en un riesgo en un riesgo
grave o moderado de inseguridad
alimentaria y para los latinoamericanos
ese porcentaje es del
46%
y no solo la pandemia es la responsable
los expertos del ipcc que le pasan
reportes a la onu sobre la crisis
climática ya habían dicho que los climas
extremos afectan el acceso a los
alimentos por ejemplo las sequías tan
prolongadas están dañando las cosechas
africanas y las de regiones de alta
montaña en asia y en américa del sur ese
calor también está haciendo que las
frutas y las verduras sean de menor
calidad del otro lado las inundaciones
están haciendo perder cultivos enteros
en suma de estos cambios estacionales
afectan los periodos para sembrar y
cosechar y según la fao los más
afectados son los pequeños productores
rurales a su vez la industria de
alimentos es una gran responsable del
calentamiento global al producir entre
el 21 y el 37 por ciento de los gases de
efecto invernadero según el ipcc la
seguridad alimentaria es aún más
vulnerable con la guerra en ucrania ya
que este país y rusia exportan el 30 por
ciento de los cereales que se producen
en todo el mundo además los rusos son
los principales exportadores de
fertilizantes que se necesitan en la
agricultura el resultado de los tres
agravantes de los que hablé a la fao es
que hay al menos 45 países que están
altamente expuestos a una crisis
alimentaria según boston consulting
group estos territorios suelen depender
en gran medida de las importaciones
tienen altos niveles de pobreza extrema
y enfrentan difíciles riesgos climáticos
como lo veíamos hay varios países
latinoamericanos que enfrentan una alta
inseguridad alimentaria a principios de
este año la fao advirtió que la hambruna
crecería en honduras haití y colombia y
el balance ha empeorado con la guerra y
con la inflación
un reporte de la ong acción contra el
hambre señala que el 85 por ciento de
los hondureños viven en zonas de
preocupación alta o muy alta de
inseguridad alimentaria y en colombia ha
aumentado la pobreza con la subida de
casi un 40% del precio de los alimentos
y de un 43 por ciento de los productos
agropecuarios importados conversamos con
martha isabel coordinadora regional
caribe de acción contra el hambre ella
nos explicó como la crisis climática
impacta a los cultivos de la región
claro que si mira ya quiero comentarte
por ejemplo el color de la zona norte
del país específicamente lo que es la
zona de la guajira una de las
situaciones más complejas que se vive es
el tema de la sequía donde los
desconocidos que es este este sistema
hace que genet no se tengan las
condiciones adecuado aprender todos los
tipos de alimentos necesarios para una
buena dieta nutricional por ejemplo
hablamos por ejemplo de centroamérica
donde también encontramos en la parte de
las aquí en otra parte las lluvias donde
están todos picos hacen que en una parte
no se den los elementos necesarios para
poder que sean en este caso se hacen
diferentes sistemas alternativos donde
se pueda generar este tipo de alimentos
en otro tipo de forma para que no afecte
en este tipo climático pero también hay
soluciones como invertir en alimentos
más saludables hay productos como el
azúcar las carnes y los cereales son los
más financiados a pesar de que son los
que más emisiones de carbono emiten por
eso la fao plantea dar más recursos a
cultivos de frutas y verduras cuyas
siembras aumentan la biodiversidad
aunque el organismo rechaza la
dependencia de los fertilizantes la fao
también habla de respaldar a los
pequeños productores quienes sólo
reciben alrededor del 17 por ciento del
financiamiento climático por su parte
martha isabel nos habló de algunos
sistemas alternos que implementan en
lugares como colombia centroamérica o
haití por en una imprenta de
alternativas técnicas que precisamente
como organizaciones estamos buscando
alternativas con la población por
ejemplo lo que son sistemas de cultivo
donde se pueden hacer por ejemplo con lo
que llamamos normalmente siempre no en
suelos sino en una una serie de como de
mesas
alternas para que el agua en caso de
lluvia no pueda tocar y podamos generar
un tipo de abono en stem para poderse
del crecimiento o también en temas de
sequía
a diferentes alternativas de árboles que
puedan generar las condiciones
climáticas para poder tener ciertos
alimentos indispensables en la dieta
familiar
y con estas soluciones terminamos
nuestra crónica ambiental vean este y
todos nuestros episodios en france24
punto com
[Música]